La suite avec Yasmine Khayat.
- Ces images sont celles
ésésésidents de la Ville occupée
de Kherson, dans le sud
de l'Ukr
vers la Place de la Liberté.
En mmememe temps, des militairs
russes vont à leur rencontre
et o
(tir)
Après avoir subisisisiège,
les bombardements, Kherson subit
les affres de la
des tirs d'armes automatiques
et de gaz laogogogènes.
(tirs et bombardements)
"Rentrez  v v vous!",
scandaient-ils, hier,
en march
russes, les forçant à faire
demi-tour.
À Marioupol, la Ville refuse
de capituler, malgré l'ultimatum
Pour Mikhaïl et sa famille,
itititituation dans la Ville
est devenue invivable.lelelelele
hier, à la faveur d'un convoi
ninininitaire, mais son fils de
trois ans et demi est toujours
traumatisé par ce qu'il a vu.
M
parle constamment d'un homme qui
rdrdrdrdrdu son bras et sa jamb,
qu'il pose encore des questions
et les avions militaires.
"C'est un crime de guerree e ef
de la diplomatie européenne,
qui dénonce ce qui se passe
à Marioupol.
ssssssssssa, la Ville se prépare
au pire. Des citoyens prennent
sont érigées.DADADADADAVID CARB,
résident d'Odessa
tente un débarquement avec les
barges et les troupes depuis la
mer parce que s'ils n'ont pas
depuis la terre, je pense
ererererererait un massacre
parce qu'ils sont vraiment
attendus, que lilililililililil.
Les troupes russes terrestres
n'arrivent pas à passer par
Mykolaiv pour arriver à Odessa,
comme on détruit les autres
villes.
- Bonjour, ça va bien?
européens, le président Zelensky
a dit qu'il n'acce
d'ultimatum.
compromis durant lesnénénénénéns
à référendum. Plus tôt, il avait
appelé avec Vladimir Poutine,
car il faut aussi déci
de l'avenir du Donbass,
où Yaryna, 26 ans, militaire
du corps des marines ukrainiens,
défend les villages
contre l'assaillant.
Elle nous parle depuis le champ
de bataille.
Durant l'entrevue,
Yaryna court se réfugier.
"Une attaque de l'aviation
russe", nous dira-t-elle
plus tard.
Yaryna ne cède ni à la colère
ni à la frustration.lelelelelele
pour sa fille de 7 ans,
évacuée aux Pays-Bas
avec des amis, car s
réquisitionné comme réserviste
de l'armée.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa